and for me he'll be making his sixth
start of the year coming off a start in
minnesota where he pitched very well six
innings gave up only four hits and one
run he walked two struck out six he
didn't get the decision but i'll tell
you what you would certainly take those
numbers here today against houston
here's abraham toro in third play and a
busy struck him out two down here's
julie guriel the right-handed hitting
first baseman swung on a high bouncer to
third ramirez will take it to the
second baseman
and get the force on brantley to end the
ending from valdez arch a ground ball
machine yeah he's gonna make his uh
his uh let me see his seventh start he's
four and one and he's 27 years old he
has pitched against cleveland one time
that was back in late april and 2019 two
scoreless innings out of the bullpen
cesar hernandez leads off and that's a
bouncing ball left side tough play
coming in toro he feels with the glove
throws to first just in time to get
hernandez
excellent job by toro on a ball that was
hugging the line and there is one away
so much soft contact with fromer on the
mound and
with a great play to get things off to a
good start to bring up kyle tucker
another left-handed band and it's swung
on and missed got him with a slider down
and in
tucker's strikeout victim number two
two down in the second
no score and boy once again j.c mejia
really looking sharp
here's the center fielder miles strong
got him swinging slide her away
and another impressive ending he has
struck out three and now the indians
have runners
at the corners with nobody out in the
second off the glove of casper to the
backstop here comes ramirez scoring
rosario to second on a very wild pitch
that is the fourth wild pitch
uncorked by fromber valdez this season
and a runner at second nobody out one
nothing tried now the indians have had
valdez on the ropes now one out double
here in the third one nothing indians
here's harold ramirez walked and scored
his first time up swung and drilled base
it up the alley right center it'll scoop
to the wall ramirez scores on his way to
second harold ramirez with an rbi double
and the indians have a two-to-nothing
lead as harold ramirez rockets one up
the right center gap his 10th double at
21st rbi
two-nothing indians
and the indians
trying to knock valdez out early
alvarez hitting 298 that's eighth in the
al 365 on base percentage 13 homers and
50 rbis and he belts one right center
field and deep and it's real deep and
it's out of here the first homer for the
astros in their last five games and it's
alvarez
and the astros are on the board his 14th
home run of the season and it's 2-1 my
goodness
that ball was wrecked
see that number 44.
that ball took 4.4 seconds to get to the
back wall of the bullpen how about that
top of the order it's jose altuve key
spot in this game base is loaded he
already has one grand slam this season
and altuve drills it pretty deep to left
field down the line it's hooking and
it's a grand slam
jose altuve goes deep and the astros
take the lead
they're up five to two
altuve's second grand slam of the season
and remember what i said about that big
swing in the bat that we didn't see
against baltimore well there you go and
he got the mistake and did not miss it
on a one-two pitch
so the astros keep the pressure on
infield is in for julie guriel and yuli
lines this one in the center field it
backs up mercado makes the catch tagging
is toro he will score without a throw a
sacrifice fly for guriel and the astros
lead is six to two leads leading tenth
sacrifice fly of the season for guriel
and you just expect him to hit it to
center field every time one down runners
at the corners ernie clement has walked
and grounded out
started at short now in left astros
leading by four the 01 and that's a
bouncing ball softly hit fielded by
garcia coming into altuve for a second
and for one and then on the first to get
the double play so that time the astros
are able to turn it six four three
second ground ball double play turned by
the astros in as many innings the astros
lead at six to two brantleys two for
three and this one's belted to right
field fair or foul if it's fair
it's gone and that is
a fair ball michael brantley
a home run back in cleveland his fifth
of the season and it was a tank job a
moon ball down the right field line for
brantley
and it's 7-2
brantley stood there and watched it
because he wasn't sure if it was going
to be fair he knew either he was going
to get another pitch or he was going to
start jogging not just a triple shot in
the cycle for brantley
from valdez went seven innings a lot of
two runs on four hits he walked five
but struck out six peter solomon
[Music]
making his third step here with the big
club
he's got a couple of games under his
belt thrown in hitting a piece
has not given up an earned run he's only
allowed one hit one walk and two
strikeouts in his time in the big
leagues
with the astros dealing with
some depth in that bullpen trying to
give some guys a day off
so ramirez at first base with one out
astros with a 7-2 lead in the bottom of
the eighth and that's popped up
shallow right side going out altuve
coming in tucker long run and altuve
makes the waist high over the shoulder
grab
back to first base goes ramirez
as harold ramirez popping out altoona
makes that play look easier than it
actually is he just blocked it to that
ball
yeah he shows up out of nowhere doesn't
he yeah
tucker
you know he's racing in thinking he
might have a play he then went into a
slide basically to avoid altuve
all right presley hasn't worked since
sunday so he'll get into this one with a
five-run lead
astros closer who has been so very good
4-1 with that 169 era and 12 out of 13
and save opportunities
opponents hitting less than 200 against
ryan presley this season and he did not
give up an earned run in that month of
june
going nine innings swinging at a miss
struck him out on the curve ball and
that is the ball game the houston astros
take the first game of this four game
set at progressive field defeating the
cleveland indians 7-2